I often get asked the question Patrick
what can I do to scale my business and
normally the first thing I'll ask them
is what the scalability even mean to you
meaning what does it mean to scale your
business well I think scalability is for
my business to grow faster or for my
business to do this or for me and and I
tell them to me scalability is for your
business to have a life of its own
where it grows with or without you
exponentially and to me exponentially is
doubles minimum is a double so if you go
from $100,000 your income to 120 to 140
to 180 to 260 that's not exponentially
exponentially is 100 to 4700 1.8 million
4.2 million that scalability and there's
a formula for that you got to keep
asking yourself what you can do to scale
your business I'm going to talk about
that today so first things first there
is a predictable side of the business
that's very important to be working on
that gives you the opportunity to scale
right a lot of times entrepreneurs will
say well I want to start scaling my
business right off the bat and they put
so much time and emphasis on scalability
business goes out it goes out of
business because they ran out of funds
they don't have money anymore and they
don't even have the opportunity scale of
the business before scalability comes
you may put five to ten percent of your
mind thinking about how to scale but you
got to put 90 percent of your effort in
producing a predictable stream of income
even if it's 10 20 30 $40,000 that's
bringing in for you to survive and not
have to worry about expenses to ask
yourself how can i scale so you're
working in the business making sales
grow in it making money you know having
some support having some help in the
business scaling the business is what
you're thinking about so how do we do
that let's talk about that people will
often tell me and say Pat listen the
reason why our business is going to
explode is because we have the most
incredible product in the world we have
the most incredible product in the world
our product is going to blow up
look rule number one of products the
best products don't always win there's a
lot of books I read
and some books I read and I'll say this
was an incredible book but it did
terrible because it wasn't a good
scalable marketing planet place in
there's some books I will just read a
book new book that just came out and
it's one of the books inc magazine
recommend as the best book store I read
I said no I didn't learn anything from
this book it's something that's been
refurbished from you know 20 blogs that
he put it into one book but because he
has a platform and made the book do very
well so his product looks better than
somebody else who may have had a great
product but terrible scalability so
product doesn't necessarily take you to
the next level the second thing is
personality there's a lot of people
that's based on their personality and
their businesses based on their
personality just think about it this way
very simple if you die or if you don't
exist what happens to your business if
you die the business dies if a business
is 100% predicated on your personality
that is not a scalable business and to
if it is you're not going to have a life
the more the business grows the more
it's going to suck you in because it's
100% predicated on your personality what
allows you to scale what allows you to
scale is if a business if a business is
built on a system the Foundation's got
to be a system a system that produces
results with the product that you have
not based on your personality this needs
to be number three if this is number one
this is number two this is number three
a great system a great system you put in
place with a good product and a decent
personality will do ten times better
than a great product a good personality
a decent system it's not going to scale
you can still make good money with great
product but if you don't have a system
you're not going to scale it you got to
have you got to make sure your system is
driving your business so systems could
be you know a step one two three
somebody comes in first they see this
then it goes to this then it goes to
threes and they buy and if they buy then
they have the option to upgrade they
have the option to upsell they have the
option to do this but this is a
streamlined system that that takes your
business to the next level now what you
need
with a great system here's what you do
need with a great system Popovich has a
system but Popovich drives the system so
you'll see some people that have the
same system as somebody else in another
business but they don't scale the
business because they're not a drivers
they're thinking the system is going to
scale their business on its own it's not
going to happen there always needs to be
a driver there triangle offense that
Phil Jackson ran with the Lakers and the
Bulls only work because he drove it okay
Popovich works because he drives it the
New England Patriots keep winning
because he has a system that works but
he is the driver he doesn't have a
personality Belichick is not a
personality guy his product is football
his product is athletes he knows how to
pick good product but he doesn't
necessarily have the best talent all the
time but he knows how to drive it he
knows how to drive it on what he does so
you got to keep in mind your system ask
yourself how well it's your system how
much your business is based on the
system and how would you drive it you'll
normally see one of these two's has a
flaw or you rely on way too much on
becoming an expert in products and way
too much on how great of a personality
you have these two have a short lifespan
this is the only thing that can have a
life of its own if there's a driver and
by the way the driver you don't have to
have the most flamboyant personality to
be a great driver you actually don't
Popovich is not the most flamboyant
personality Phil Jackson is not the most
flamboyant personality but Belichick is
not the most flamboyant person out
there's a lot more coaches with
flamboyant personalities but they're not
as good of drivers drivers do things
that you and I never see drivers do
things that happens right here behind
the desk right there at a conference
table right here we're meeting happens
that they know how to drive a vendor
they know how to drive a partner and
employ an executive a team member a
client they know how to drive that
behind closer that nobody sees that the
average person cannot because they're
just happy with a system they have in
place now there's still one more message
here on how to scale your business
there's five more steps on scaling your
business and I'm going to leave the last
one because I'll tato last one what it
is but but I want to make sure you get
it at the end five steps to scaling one
thinking big it's very simple but very
few people do it it doesn't get doesn't
take much believe it or not to fill
somebody's appetite
it really doesn't very few people think
big continuously now think about it
somebody may say well I'm a bigger
thinker than my friends I get it but
being a bigger thinking and your friends
doesn't mean you're a big thinker you're
a small thinker amongst great thinkers
right so if you always compare yourself
to your friend I'm a bigger thinking of
my sister my brother my cousin my nephew
my niece you're probably going to be a
cool big thinker amongst your friends
because you make 280 a year or whatever
your business is doing resume all
respect to you whatever level you're at
with your business if you're happy with
it that's fine but to have it scale and
have a life of its own you're not
watching this video to find out how to
get your business from 240 to 280 that's
not the purpose of this video there's
plenty of videos on YouTube to show you
how to do that there's plenty of
articles to read this is about scaling
your business and if you're not refusing
to think big don't count on it being
scale it's not going to happen right
there needs to be a big thinker behind
it
Apple happened because there was a
product expert called Wozniak that I had
a chance of interviewing but behind it
there was a driver called Jobs who drove
it because he was a big thinker Amazon
has a big thinker anything you think
about its scales there's typically a big
thinker there too don't celebrate the
celebration lifespan sometimes is too
long you know people get one victory one
vendor oh my god we got this big client
that's going to give us six hundred
thousand dollars of business per year
this is so exciting let's go to bar
today hey our game is on me let's go to
the Laker game let's go to the next game
it's on me let's go to watch the
Warriors play let's go ahead beer
tonight drinks it way way too much
celebration a big thinker doesn't
necessarily celebrate a big vendor
coming on board because they're
expecting that to happen because they're
thinking big a small thinkers life span
of celebration is way way too long
that's why they rarely skill because the
moment they make $50,000 a month
and in their mind they're not they're
getting paid way more than what they're
worth because their entire goal is tied
to on money because they get to that
point they don't experience what it is
to explode and scale they stay there too
long three is in on you got to spend the
time working on your business but no one
went there's a certain timing here so if
this is a pendulum okay if this is a
pendulum this is n this is on you spend
majority of your time working in your
business and then gradually within 6 12
24 18 you know whatever months then
you're spending more time on and and
eventually you're working more on your
business than you are in your business
but you got a time this well sometimes
people go on too early and sometimes net
people never leave end because they're
controlling and they want to micromanage
everything and they never experienced
scalability so this is a timing fact
that you have to deal with and then it's
the highest return you you got a you
know a lot of times as a CEO I run a
firm at I run a financial from PHP
agency' and I'm running the firm and
we'll have a problem that'll come up
okay we have a challenge that we have
with with anything it could be many
different platforms that we have a
challenge and we'll have a meeting and
I'll say okay how can we solve this
problem and we'll make a list we'll
process this together we'll make a list
and we'll say if we do this we can do
this if we do this we can if we do this
perfect that solves the problem right
yes but it's not the optimal solution
it's a solution it's not the optimal
solution I'm looking for the optimal
solution the optimal solution is what is
going to be able to put us in a position
to not have to face this issue again six
months from now or are we simply putting
a bandaid on this problem that we have
to face seven months later and why are
we doing that a lot of times when when
you're a leader of a business the
entrepreneur you'll face an issue I see
too often trying to build a business
with band-aids then actually sitting
down and saying what can I do for this
pain to go away that's what I'm looking
for because I don't want to have more
issues coming out later on that we're
looking at having to overcome six seven
eight months later no optimal solution
so if I can invest money back into my
business and I sit then we're having a
meeting we
$300,000 put back into the business
great I think we should do it here we
should do it here we should do it here
square let's hire three new people and
pop up a pop out that's what we need to
be doing excellent let's do that awesome
great job our guys that know what can we
do to get the highest possible return
that's the optimal solution to scale the
business to the next level and not just
throw money away at something that'll
give us 6% return why don't we spend
another hour in the meeting and try to
find out what's going to give us 13
percent return and let's sleep on it or
find out tomorrow what we can do to get
a 19% return and maybe we find out we
can to 29% return if we do this optimal
solution scalability and the last one I
left blank because the last one is an
art the last one is an art the last one
is an art that that you know it takes a
while to learn and you're continuously
going to learn this and if if the last
one is something that you don't touch if
the last one is something that you don't
embrace you're lowering the chances of
you being able to skate it can still
scale but the last one is going to give
you the highest level of scalability and
that is leverage leverage leverage
leverage so how do you leverage look
know when you don't have all the answers
and you bring somebody in who's the
opposing strength of you if you're pure
you know profit visionary type of a CEO
and you're terrible with operations
don't try to be operations
you've got to leverage somebody with
operations to help you with the systems
to increase the speed if you're an
Operations type of person and you're not
a great driver you're just purely
operations and your driving skills are
not good you need to bring a driver to
be able to drive the company don't try
to be a CEO known behind closed doors
you are an operation guy you keep only
thinking about that and no wonder
there's not somebody driving a business
maybe you're a good CFO and you need
help with in operations or see your
percent all you care about is money
money money you're always worried about
we can't spend money on that we can't
spend money we can spend on it and
because of how cheap you are you don't
know how to leverage somebody else to
tell you we need to invest into this we
need to buy this software we need to go
and do it we need to invest into
marketing you're not going to scale with
leverage is partner
ships right vendors a partner that's
going to come that you may have to give
something in return
to be able to scale the business with
that's all leverage so what can you do
to leverage time what can you do to
leverage your business what can you do
to leverage your vendors what can you do
to leverage your partners what can you
do to leverage the executive team around
you what can you do to leverage your
team you know consultants what can you
do to leverage someone that's going to
help you scale the business not somebody
just throw money away either you don't
you don't hire aggressively all the time
you're hiring very slow you're firing
very fast but all you're thinking about
is what position can I put myself into
to help me to leverage the business to
scale it to a whole different level that
I possibly couldn't do by myself and if
you do those things it's not just a one
area you got to go back and watch this
video one more time and ask yourself am
i spending more time on predictable side
or scalable sign am i more product
person am i more personality do i drive
my business based on system you know
what am I most of the time working on
this and then ask yourself these five
areas how well you are and then slowly
but surely ask yourself what phase of
this business you are and on start
asking yourself I want to scale how do i
scale how do I do this how do I do that
and slowly but surely you'll get better
at that and then all of a sudden the
year you have a double-double it's got
to be a minimum of a double that's
scaling your business when you start
having some bevels in measureable
numbers that you're looking at that is
doubling that's scalability that's my
message to you about scaling if you got
any questions about it comment on the
bottom and if you haven't subscribed to
this channel please do so as well thanks
for watching